we are end game I know that
and you know that
it's hard to believe it's been a decade
since the unexpected passing of Glee's
Corey Monteith and today his former love
and co-star Leah Michelle has taken to
Instagram to reflect on the 10-year
anniversary of his passing
Finn
he and he loved all of you guys during a
Sentimental black and white photo of the
pair on her feed Leah wrote hey you 10
years It Feels Like Only Yesterday that
you were here and yet a million years
ago all at the same time I hold all of
our memories in my heart where they will
stay safe and never forgotten we miss
you every day and we'll never forget the
light you brought to us all I miss you
big guy ending her tribute post to Corey
Leah seemingly referenced the late Foo
Fighters drummer Taylor Hawkins who died
unexpectedly in March 2022 writing I
hope you found Taylor up there and are
playing the drums together prioritically
Corey was an avid drummer and was part
of an indie rock band called Bonnie Dune
even occasionally flexing his drumming
skills on episodes of Glee
Can't Stop
again
not only did Leah and Corey Play Each
Other's Love interests Rachel Berry and
Finn Hudson on Glee but the set of the
hitbox show was also where their real
love story began the pair began to date
in 2012 until Corey's unexpected
overdose on July 13 2013 at the age of
31. shortly after his death the cast of
Glee honored the actor with an episode
titled the quarterback which mourned the
loss of both the character Finn and of
Corey I can still see his face and and
can hear his voice so clearly
do you think that I'll ever forget it